so i'm gonna become a bartender
[Music]
here we go the first drink everybody the
first drink
jesus what first drink is whiskey
all right now i'm not explaining to the
whiskey
oh [ __ ] holy [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] good at
this
ah i'm pouring into my eyes
my eyes it should be burning
look at this bottle flip though whoa
bottle flip and beyond wow
oh my god
is bottle flipping still cool
[ __ ] you
[Music]
okay all right who wants a whiskey all
right we grab a glass
excellent i you looking thirsty but
okay that's great but good game good
game everyone all right you want ice
what are you [ __ ] gay who adds
whiskey who adds
ice to your whiskey you want some want
anything else to ruin a perfectly good
drink
all right next one vodka on the rocks
excellent choice my friend we got some
vodka
right here with ice
and a lemon i meant a lemon
whoa that was cool yeah
this is cool i like this now i'm going
to make the same drink
in real life let's see how it goes
okay here we go my first drink
vodka tonic i won't be needing these
now first of all we gotta get the glass
which are over here
yes got my glass hell yeah
what up there we go that's
now let me just get that vodka that is
over
here ah is it the vodka
i think it is feels like a yes that's
what
it smells smells nice now let me
just pour three ounces of vodka
for you
there you go what's that is that enough
for you sir
okay let me just get some ice
let me try that again where is this
glass there it is
ah let me get some of that tonic for you
boy
what's it vodka tonic where
there you go and served please
[Music]
that looks pretty good
that is pretty good actually huh
oh [ __ ] wait actually how could i forget
about
the lamb the fresh lamb
so much better with a nice slice of lamb
orange
[Music]
so it's always better when i make it
it's kind of a cool chill game i
actually like it
you know i used to work at a bartender
once
i say once because i was never hired
again
whiskey cola coming right up my man let
me just
get me a glass a glass that i keep
keep right here there we go that's the
wrong
line is it no that's perfect all right
what's what's cracking yeah is this
making anyone anxious i think yes okay
let me get that whiskey
hey yeah whoa whoa what just happened
okay we're fine now just uh how much you
want three ounces
three ounces of whiskey now i'm not
really a fan of
mixing with cola but you know you gotta
you gotta do what you gotta do all right
there you go now let's just get
now let's just get the coca-cola
you want ice for that boy i got you
[Music]
whiskey cola coming right up
this is just an excuse for me to drink
school for fun
[Music]
here we go another drink everyone that's
exciting
a gin on the rocks hey we got some nice
hannigan gin everybody hell yeah
oh my god oh
what are the odds what are the odds
i legit wonder if i can juggle in vr
[Music]
the answer is no the answer is no
everyone okay
all right here we go vodka on the what
it changed
oh [ __ ] sake okay here's the gin on
the rocks
[Music]
perfect who wants a jet on the rocks
i'm burping a lot okay here we go let me
just get that glass
being a bartender is awesome man it's
the best
all right let me just get my gin it's
exactly where i want it so [ __ ]
is this the gin it's the gin
okay let me just pour that for you
you want anything else with that boy
don't worry about it don't worry about
it fine
you want some ice
no i got you fam don't worry about it
there you go jen on the jen on the rocks
or uh
jin on the rock this has been
my pleasure i'm in the med jeff
and uh thank you for watching
if you ever want to come by the the pie
bar just hit me up
on craigslist i i come i do parties
every wednesday and if you guys want to
leave a like uh
and support my patreon for a chance to
become an alcoholic hit me up
and just reach out to my agent his name
is
[Music]
jeff